[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les petits amis bon notre
nounours n'est vraiment pas prudent
depuis ce matin il se promène avec son
gros portefeuilles au me je fais
attention patron
et puis je ne vais pas le perdre en
allant chez papa d'elle et du cola fait
attention nounours
ne vous inquiétez pas patron pendant
pourront prendre pour soi maison m'a dit
d'automne on peut pas de veille
oui c'est du marocain c'est ma maman qui
me l'a donnée est appelée jazz des dames
ou savez j'ai des tickets de métro notre
guise
mon argent de poche et des photos de ma
famille alors montre non non non
c'est amusant s'est réjoui 9,5 satisfait
c'est ma maman et ma soeur et mia avec
moi quand j'étais un petit pouce entêté
bien mignon comme le gentil tu ne sais
pas de caprice jetait un enfant excuses
en pleurs
[Musique]
je me souviens
quand je te petit jeu
sous vivant
debart
petite maman chérie
e
[Musique]
vva
faire les courses il ya plus de là
en apposant nous
moi je répondais j'y cours maman joli
haut et vite chaleur jusqu'à la berge
bruit quand j'étais 10 heures
[Musique]
masri biya me de monde
tut abuseurs avec moi j'aurai pour leur
jeu
benoît maes truire au camp
bush voulait
savoir lire écran il
ma soeur emilie a joué à la mare à boue
en ce sont l'eau
je l'appelle à vue
il ya longtemps mais je n'oublie pas que
ma maman à tous
jour et détenir 2 mois
oh oui vraiment bien se conduire au sel
faire plaisir à sa chute
le mamelon
ce que tu chantes bien non j'étais très
jeune quand tu étais petit jeu tu es bon
tu sais on est très gentil aussi avec
notre mamie oui les potes à moi je suis
la vaisselle moi aussi c'est très
violent et plus humain tenons à lui où
tout doux elle est formidable la famille
henry etc soir tel écho chez sagement au
mon but est que j'étais dans moule
ma maman chérie et tenait la lune leurs
[Musique]
profits
pour le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais voici notre nounours et il n'a pas
perdu son portefeuille au nom patron lot
de photos de ma maman de dons c'est bien
nounours allons en août
bonfils bonne nuit les enfants faites de
beaux rêves
faute de boer bonne
[Musique]